Speaker 1: So sometimes I'll say kind of metaphorically,
that Trump rallies and Trump events are sort
of like these circus tent evangelical churches,
but we don't literally mean that.
But Trump's rally in Selma, North Carolina,
over the weekend actually really seemed like
one.
Madison Cawthorn, the radical Republican Trump
is a congressman who is in a wheelchair.
He's paralyzed.
I guess it's from the waist down from a car
accident.
He did a sort of reenactment of the type of
scene you would normally see, like in an evangelical
faith healing church where he performed a
miracle and stood up using his arms, holding
himself up on on a walker type thing.
With the help of two people and metal braces
on his on his legs, I believe and this is
it's horrible on so many levels and I'm going
to talk about it.
So let's I'm going to play the clip for you
if you're only listening what I'm going to.
It's important that I describe that.
What's going on is he is performing a miracle
by standing despite being paralyzed from the
waist down.
Just look at this.
Speaker 2: Seven dollars a gallon.
My friends, this country can change very quickly
and it may seem impossible.
People tell me that it's impossible to change
the direction of our country, that it's impossible
without the corruption in our government.
Speaker 1: Here he goes.
So they bring out a walker and then two people
kind of stand him up.
This is a miracle that he's performing.
Speaker 2: But my friends, God spared my life.
He has given me the strength to stand before
you today, so do not lecture me on what is
impossible.
My fellow Patriots Americans are in the business
of doing the impossible, because with God,
all things are possible.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So listen, first of all, of course, no disrespect
to us, to his physical condition whatsoever.
I wish he had never gotten into that car accident.
I wish he had full use of his legs.
Of course, of course.
Of course, I would never ridicule anyone for
I mean, he he has a terrible medical condition.
It's horrible.
OK, but what are the issues here?
First of all, it's not like he stood up and
walked around.
And so even this framing of with God, anything
is possible.
Well, why didn't God keep you out of the accident?
Why didn't God give you the ability to walk
rather than just standing in this way?
I mean, it's it's no disrespect to him.
It's great that he can stand on the strength
of his arms.
That's a beautiful thing.
That's better than not being able to do it.
But why is it if you're invoking that God
did these things, why wouldn't God have spared
you from the accident or from the paralysis?
It just doesn't make any sense.
These are indivisible, feasible comments,
first of all.
Secondly, FDR used to do this.
OK, FDR.
Did this without fanfare?
He didn't say it's God's work.
FDR didn't weaponize his physical problem
to try to sucker people into supporting anything
in particular.
FDR had actual policy ideas.
And that's part of it.
It's sad that it works with this crowd and
it, you know, it's also not super surprising
that there's this palpable lack of authentic
spirituality that pervades the Republican
Party.
It performative charlatan ism.
And that's what we saw here from Madison Cawthorn.
You don't see this and go.
That is some authentic spirituality, you go.
That's that's like the type of act you would
expect at a faith healing church.
And it is classic cult stuff.
I may do a deeper dove into this later this
week or next week.
There is a book called Thought Reform and
the Psychology of Total ISM A Study of Brainwashing
in China.
It's written by Robert Jay Lifton.
This is a fantastic book, and it talks about
the different elements for brainwashing people
what is sometimes called thought reform.
And one of the items on the list is what's
called mystical manipulation.
The manipulation of experiences that appears
spontaneous, but it's actually planned and
orchestrated by the group or its leaders to
demonstrate divine authority, spiritual advancement,
exceptional talent or insight that sets the
leader apart from humanity and allows a reinterpretation
of historical events, scripture and other
experiences.
That is exactly what Madison Cawthorn is doing
here.
He's doing this mystical manipulation where
he is able to rise up and stand despite being
paralyzed.
Cawthorn also does number three.
Number three is a demand for purity.
The world is viewed as black and white.
Everybody is exhorted to conform to the ideology
of the group and to strive for perfection.
And they use guilt and shame to control people.
His recent stuff with the orgies and the cocaine
he presents himself as he's pure.
He's been told that the orgies in the cocaine
go on.
He doesn't participate in it.
He's the pure one.
Sacred science is another item from the list
of criteria for thought reform.
The group's doctrine or ideology is considered
to be the ultimate truth beyond questioning
and dispute.
Truth is not found outside the group.
The leader, as the spokesperson for God or
Humanity, is likewise above criticism.
This is more general to Trumpism, Trump literally
has said.
You don't believe what you're seeing.
Don't believe what you're hearing.
I will tell you what's really going on.
I will give you the truth.
And then lastly, from this list.
Loading the language the group interprets
or uses words and phrases in new ways.
So that often the outside world doesn't understand.
This includes thought terminating cliches
which serve to alter members thought process
to conform the group's way of thinking.
They do that all the time.
For example, fake news.
That's a thought terminating cliché.
It's not.
It's not really fake news.
It's just news you disagree with.
It's reporting that's not good for you.
That's fake news.
That's it.
Or, hey, you know what?
That was incredibly insensitive and discriminatory.
What?
You're Oh, you're woke.
That's another thought terminating cliche.
This is incredible how closely their behavior
conforms to these brainwashing techniques,
and we will talk about that more